I'm joined today by Mark Godsey who's
the co-founder of the Ohio Innocence
Project which to date has freed 25
wrongly convicted people from prison who
served the combined 470 years he is also
author of blind injustice a former
prosecutor exposes the psychology and
politics of wrongful convictions so much
to talk about here mark I really
appreciate you joining me let's first
start with how you got into even the
idea of working to help free people who
have been wrongly imprisoned well it's
actually an interesting story because
it's kind of by accident I was a
prosecutor in New York City for many
years and was prosecutors prosecutor
very hard-nosed enjoyed my job but
wanted to go into academia and be a
criminal law professor and so the first
job I got was actually at a different
school than where I am now that the
first year I was there they they had a
pre-existing Innocence Project and the
professor who ran it was on sabbatical
my first year so the Dean comes up to me
and is like hey you know you're the new
creme guy you've got criminal
investigation experience or your
background so you're gonna have to run
this Innocence Project and I you know I
didn't say this out loud but I sort of
thought to myself oh my gosh you know I
can't really say no but what a stupid
idea because I didn't think innocent
people got convicted and I remember
going to the first meeting with the
students and they had gone to prison and
interviewed this inmate named Herman May
and they were going on and on about how
they were so convinced he was innocent
and I remember just you know asking
about the case and just thinking oh my
god these students are so naive yeah
this guy's totally guilty but then DNA
testing was done and it excluded him
from the crime scene evidence he was
exonerated and released and so it's
really just sort of if I call the first
chapter of the book I open her because
that's what that first year was a huge
eye-opener that I never would have ever
like sort of been enlightened about this
problem had I not been forced into it
and so that year I went through it you
sort of a year of discovery the next
year I got a job at the University of
Cincinnati Law School which is my
hometown and Ohio is the largest state
that didn't have an Innocence Project
and so I was such a believer in that one
year of time that I founded the one here
with John Cranley who's now the mayor of
Cincinnati and so we've been in
operation now since 2003 and you said
something interest
is that when you were a prosecutor you
didn't believe that innocent people got
convicted did you not ever have a case
that you prosecuted where you had doubts
as to the guilt of the accused well you
know that's one of the things I that's
one of the reasons why I wrote the book
is because at the time no I mean in our
mentality in the office it was everybody
brought to us by the police or by the
FBI agents or whatever they're obviously
guilty there was no sort of
open-mindedness to us whatsoever but I
now that I've been doing innocence work
I've been on the other side for all
these years I look back on some of my
cases and the mentality I had and I'm
open to questioning and I certainly am
concerned about some of the ways that I
behaved as a prosecutor and I saw other
prosecutors behave around me and so that
in many ways the book is a confessional
and a memoir I cut back and forth
between innocence work and sort of like
the way I see police and prosecutors
behave that cause these wrongful
convictions and I cut back to you know
the way it was when I was in the
prosecutor's office and how we did those
very same things and so in Chapter 7 of
the book I talk about one of the cases
where I very well now looking back at it
with a more objective mind the guy might
be innocent I don't know I really had
tunnel vision I spun the evidence and
and and you know I wasn't open-minded
about it any evidence that came forward
I was gonna spin it in a way to make it
look guilty which is what everyone did
in my office and what I see happened
that causes these wrongful convictions
now so you know it's certainly a
complete metamorphosis in my in my frame
of mind I would say so we'll get to how
the Innocence Project works a case and
how you you get some of these
convictions get some of these people
freed but before we get to that let's
talk first a little bit about how people
are wrongfully convicted to begin with
is it a combination of circumstance
prosecutorial techniques the plea plea
agreement industrial complex or call it
whatever it is you want to call it talk
to us a little bit about how people end
up being wrongly convicted yeah I mean
it's it's a variety of factors you
talked about you know the plea bargain
machine that we have a lot of innocent
people plead guilty but you know the
ones we're finding are from the people
that didn't plead guilty because trying
to undo pleas is so difficult at this
point our criminal justice system is
really not ready to accept it it's very
very difficult and so you know we've had
over 2000 exonerations in the innocence
movement the past 25 years almost all of
those the vast majority
those are from people who did not plead
guilty and something like 96 percent of
people plead guilty so we're getting all
these exonerations out of the small
percentage like 4% that actually went to
trial so I mean it just tells you that
the the number of people who pled guilty
that we can't even touch their cases is
very troubling it's it's a variety of
things I mean I think the biggest
misconception I deal with this in my
book is that the public sort of thinks
and the families of the wrongfully
convicted think this is like evil people
and the prosecutors are doing this on
purpose a lot of it is just mentality
and psychology there was a great
arrogance in our system and these you
know prosecutors and judges and even
defense attorneys become bureaucrats
after a while there's sort of going
through the motions or not looking at
the evidence objectively anymore they
assume everybody's guilty and so they're
not sitting there you know thinking
hahahahaha I'm gonna convict an innocent
person they just become close-minded and
they become so biased in their
evaluation of the cases that they're no
longer looking at them objectively and
fairly and I talk about how I did that
as a prosecutor
it's tunnel vision it's confirmation
bias there's a whole chapter on how
confirmation bias affects the judgments
of police and prosecutors even forensic
experts you know the system basically
what it comes down to is our criminal
justice system right now is operating on
an understanding of the human mind
understanding of psychology from the
1800s or at best the 1950s and our
understanding of the human mind has
changed so much but the criminal justice
system hasn't caught up so for example
wrongful convictions are caused many of
them by human memory problems you know
eyewitnesses are so easily open to
suggestion and you can as a prosecutor
and a police officer you can bend their
statements to fit your theories of the
case but we tend to in the court system
think that eyewitnesses come and testify
and say I'm a hundred percent positive
that's the guy did it
but that's ironclad evidence it's
actually really weak evidence because
you know human memory is very very weak
and particularly the way we handle it in
the criminal justice system we
contaminate it and what be an example of
the opposite I'm interested because
obviously the idea that someone comes in
and says I'm a hundred percent sure this
is how it happened we know that that's
that that's that's not really the case
but can you give us an example of how a
prosecutor might take a witness that
does not seem to have 100% recollection
and
use the power of suggestion to create a
particular impression upon the jury oh
yeah I knew that I talk about this all
the time I mean I did it as a prosecutor
I saw it done around me all the time
I'll give you a perfect example I get
many of them in the book you know you
got a case where you think the murder
happened at 11 o'clock and you know that
the the guy who's your suspect was in
the bar that evening and so you pull a
couple witnesses in and the first couple
people who were in the bar that day say
yeah I think he left around 10:30 and he
came back around 11:30 and so as a
prosecutor you're going bingo right
that's perfect that's he was gone right
when the murder happened he had time to
get there to commit the murder and get
back you call the third witness in and
the third witness goes you know what he
was there till midnight well what does
that mean for you as a police officer a
prosecutor that's that's an alibi that
means the guy couldn't have done it and
so in the mine frame you're in as a
police officer prosecutor you just
assume this person has to be wrong and
so you start grilling them I mean are
you sure I think really hard because you
know other people are telling us bah
blah blah blah blah and it doesn't take
that off that much to get some witnesses
and many witness will start bending and
they'll start saying you know the more I
think about it you're probably you know
I think he had left by the time the
football game was over and it starts to
line up now with the time frame that the
prosecution had all along now just a
procedural question is it allowed to
reference other testimony to someone
you're questioning in that way is it
okay to say well other witnesses have
said this other thing you're not you're
not supposed to there's no official rule
against it I mean the defense attorney
can get on the stand and say you know
did they suggest to you what to say did
they tell you what other witnesses are
saying right and some witnesses might
say yeah they said that but it didn't
affect my you know it didn't affect me
or they may say no they told me that you
know but you know they can be done more
subtly you know you can if you're after
you're a prosecutor police officer and
you're asking those pointed questions
over and over again you don't even have
to say that's what other witnesses are
telling us you know you can be looking
each other that you know the prosecutor
looks at the police officer and they
stare at each other and they just look
shake their heads and dis plead the
witness gets the message after a while
that they're wrong mm-hm and that they
should be really thinking about it and
then you come back to me say look I want
you to think really hard about this
that's not jiving up with what we're
hearing you know this happens and what I
talk about in the book that is even more
alarming is in my prosecutor's office
when a witness changed their statement
to
our prodding it was often the case that
we didn't write it down we didn't write
down what their first statement it was
so that the original defense attorney at
trial never finds out that there was an
evolution so doesn't get a chance to
cross-examine them and say hey wait a
minute didn't you first say that he was
there until midnight that means he
couldn't expended the murder and when I
first started I was told you know don't
write that down because you got a really
Prada witness on their memory and to
help them understand and help them
remember and help them understand how
serious this is to tell the truth and
once you get them you know once they
come to Jesus which means give the right
answers they're supposed to give her you
want them to give then you write it down
but anything before that is just an
offhand comment it's not official you
know you really have to prod their
memory first and you know at the time I
didn't understand how malleable human
memory was so I sort of bought into the
theory like you know we really know what
happened we've got the whole file this
guy if he says something that disagrees
with what we think he's dead wrong and
so it's our job to correct him now that
I understand human memory better
I understand how we were doing what's
called a call the book synthesized
testimony we are creating testimony to
fit our theory of the case we're
speaking with Mark Godsey who's
co-founder of the Ohio Innocence Project
the book is blind injustice a former
prosecutor exposes the psychology and
politics of wrongful convictions we'll
pause on our conversation with him and
continue with more tomorrow we're
continuing our conversation with Mark
Godsey who's the co-founder of the Ohio
Innocence Project which has freed 25
wrongly convicted people who served the
combined 470 years in prison he's also
author of blind injustice a former
prosecutor exposes the psychology and
politics of wrongful convictions before
we move on to how you work to free
people of mark one other thing I want to
touch on is how much of a factor do you
believe it is in terms of wrongful
convictions that a lot of a lot of
people just don't have the money for
better defense attorneys and they may
not be receiving the best defense
particularly from overloaded public
defenders who might have 50 or even
several hundred cases at a time yeah I
talked about that in detail in chapter 3
of the book there's a great imbalance in
the system you know when I was a
prosecutor if I needed a fancy CSI
expert to come and spend the evidence a
particular way any kind of expert or
Bell and whistle I needed to get
conviction I had as a defendant you know
unless you're really rich I mean the
public sometimes see these defenses from
like Michael Jackson or OJ Simpson and
they think that's what everybody gets
and you know not at all public defenders
are overworked I think in Louisiana one
of them said that they get an average of
seven minutes they can spend on each
case you know it varies from
jurisdiction to jurisdiction but they
don't have the funds to hire
investigators to go out and beat the
streets and find witnesses they don't
have the funds for all these bells and
whistles and fancy experts and all this
kind of stuff I mean in some cases they
can ask and they can get some funds but
as a defense attorney you've got to pick
and choose because if you're asking too
much the judges are gonna get tired of
you so the average defendant is really
out of resources disadvantage one of the
reasons why I love the documentary
making a murderer and I hope that
everybody who's interested in this issue
watches it is that you can see that
disparity play out in great detail
there's two defendants in the case that
are charged in Steven Avery has a lot of
money because he just won a civil case
and so he hires Dean Strang and and
Jerry blanking on his name but you know
they do a fantastic job I mean they
can't get better defense attorneys than
that and then the other defendant
Brendan Dassey gets a public defender
and one after the other who just you
know sells him down the river basically
admits in court that he's guilty before
even interviews as his own client and so
you can see that disparity now I don't
mean to disparage public defenders I
mean they're doing a thankless job and
they're overworked and underpaid and
they have big hearts and all these sorts
of things but a lot of places you get
some of them that's become burned-out
and they're going through the motions
and you know if it's your child who's
charged with this crime
you're gonna want somebody who's who's
not doing that who's invested and has
the resources but you know that's rare
so when you get involved first of all I
mean how do you even pick which cases to
work on right how do you first determine
before you start actually making the
case to the system that someone may have
been wrongfully convicted you have to
sort of research the case for yourself
so what's that process like for you to
decide what cases to take on yeah it's a
very fluid process so since we started
in 2003 we've had over 8,000 Ohio
inmates write to us we investigate a
pretty high percentage I'd say 50% of
all off the top you can cut kind of
early because it's clear they're not
claiming innocence they're saying I did
it but I
too long of a sentence or you know
things like that they're sort of
admitting it we're only looking for
people that are totally innocent and so
the other 50% sort of go on a conveyor
belt and they start falling off and
eventually after you can just keep going
for a while you have these cases that
are still on the conveyor belt you know
they still look good after that you
continue to investigate and investigate
so the first thing we do is if it seems
to meet our criteria the persons
claiming they're innocent you know we
just investigate as much as we can about
the case from the paper what you can
find on the internet newspaper articles
the decisions from the case from the
court we will do public records requests
and get the police files in the
prosecutors file so we're looking for
was there DNA collected at the time by
the police that hasn't been tested that
can tell us one way or another that's an
easy low-hanging fruit you know if you
got a guy saying he's innocent who's
convicted of rape and there's a rape kit
there that had semen collected it was
never tested but we can get an answer
right now you know fairly quickly
whether he's innocent or guilty in other
cases it's much more complicated there's
no DNA that can get sort of give us a
quick answer you know it involves going
back and talking to the witnesses from
20 years ago when the person was
convicted and you know a lot of times
you do that and everything is the same
they sort of say yeah I saw what I saw
on the guy's guilty and but you know
with a lot of these people claiming
innocence you start looking into it and
it starts to smell a little bit you
start hearing you know I lied for this
reason or that you know the police are
pressuring me they were sort of
manipulating my testimony or you know
you do a public records request and you
get the police file and you find all
this exculpatory evidence all this stuff
that points to the defendants innocence
that the police never turned over which
they're required to under the
constitutional Brady doctrine so we want
to think last six of our cases in a row
then because the police
suppress hid evidence that pointed to
innocence back at the time of trial so
there's all sorts of different angles I
mean we're just basically rolling up our
sleeves like old fashioned detectives
and looking into these cases and seeing
if they still hold water after 20 30 40
years and legally speaking a court can
decide whether or not they will allow
you to even go through the process of
challenging an old conviction right I
mean there's no guarantee that you you
would even get that opportunity is that
right well we can file what's called a
post-conviction motion motion for new
trial which is a brief that'll have all
the evidence attached and half a day
for more the DNA test reports and it's
up to the court to decide whether it
meets the legal standards to reopen the
case and I gotta tell you there's a lot
of variance I mean a system I mean
chapter 2 of my book is called blind
denial and it's about how the system is
basically in denial about this problem
everybody sort of smugly believes that
wrongful convictions don't happen even
after we've been proving they happen you
know many judges and prosecutors no
matter what the evidence they're not
going to admit the mistakes been made
and so at the first step it's sort of a
real crapshoot do you have a judge who's
been enlightened to this problem and can
actually look at the evidence in an open
mind and many times we have overwhelming
evidence of innocence and we lose
there's a saying when I started doing
this work I think it was barry scheck
but one of the leaders in the movement
said you know no matter how strong your
evidence of innocence is you're probably
going to lose in the trial court in the
county where the conviction happened
because the judge and then the
prosecutors are politically entrenched
even if they're not the same party you
know they sort of depend on each other
but the more you get away and the
appellate courts after you lose and you
appeal and ultimate you get to federal
court the more you would get away from
the prosecutors home court you're
getting a more objective view you have a
better chance of winning and I've seen
that time and time again where we've got
overwhelming evidence but we lose and
then a couple years later we finally win
in some appellate court or in federal
court in habeas and that's a real shame
because the innocent person had to sit
in prison sub Rios extra time because of
course didn't wanna admit they made a
mistake so reopening cases and then
particularly appealing these one or
numerous times that sounds expensive how
is this all funded I spend a lot of my
time I started off doing this work as a
professor sort of like the high school
social studies teacher who starts on the
cross team and stays after school did
like teach you know coach it was just me
as a professor doing this for free and
working with the students and we got so
many cases that I started shifting to
fund raising in order to build an
infrastructure I spent a lot of time
doing that now private fund raising and
grants we've got now like a staff of
like seven full-time people and twenty
students and workforce in any given time
so we're like a law firm and we're doing
a lot of work so it's it's it's funded
through the generosity of a lot of
different donors and who really step up
and understand this problem and have
made this all possible and you talked
about how there may be political
reasons why prosecutors or judges may
not take particularly kindly to the work
you're doing but in in a broader sense
are there groups that are opposed to
what you're doing in a more general
sense I mean you would think that hey
there it's possible some people have
been wrongfully convicted and we should
all want them not to be in prison it
seems like everybody should be in favor
of that but it's not often but that
simple is it well everyone will give lip
service to it so what a prosecutor will
say is oh the innocence projects are
great I mean boy this is important to
have this kind of work but this case
you've made a mistake
mm-hmm it's sort of like surveys of
Congress you know sometimes the public
will say you know you have Congress very
low marks like ten percent approval
rating but if you ask him if their
congressman is doing a good job they get
very high ratings so it's like they only
think everybody else's Congress person
is the one who's thinking up the joy you
know everybody looks sad they go yeah
there's some wrongful convictions I'll
admit I've read that in the paper they
happen but not in this office not that
case that's my case so it's that sort of
like not me you know mistakes were made
but not by me sort of mentality when it
comes to false confessions which is
something that is is a is a frequent
issue that comes up and that could be
because someone was coerced or for
whatever other reason can you talk a
little bit about the sort of
psychological dynamics that play into
that the different reasons whether there
may be so-called false confessions sure
there's there's three types one is just
a compliant where somebody who's it's
usually it doesn't happen very often but
somebody's mentally ill and you remember
the John but a Ramsey case from years
ago mark Kimber's last name got all this
publicity by walking into the police
department saying I'm the one that
killed her but they remember that well
yeah so it's usually somebody who's
mentally ill that tries to claim that
they committed a crime they did and that
doesn't happen very often other than
that there's two major categories one is
where the person is coerced
I'm just intensive interrogation for
hours and hours and hours and here's a
dirty little secret the public doesn't
generally know police officers are
allowed to and do lie to suspects in the
interrogation room they'll do these
little stunts where the phone will ring
in the interrogation room and the
officer will answer it go huh that's
very interesting we just got the DNA
reports and your DNA was found on the
bloody knife now you can't even run DNA
test that quickly but they lie and then
the person sitting there you know
they're exhausted this has been going on
forever they start to and then the
officer starts to say you know your only
opportunity really to avoid the death
penalty is to tell me now I hope you
I'll get leniency all we want to do is
figure out what happened and we know
that you were provoked and we know this
was probably self-defense and so they
get them thinking I I have no choice I'm
going to get convicted and a rational
person starts to decide the lesser evil
is this is just to go along with what
the police said and I know everybody
says that I would never falsely confess
to a crime I didn't commit
but it happens and I if you if you're
saying that now I would encourage you to
read John Grisham's the innocent man
it's his only non-fiction book and
there's about a twenty page passage in
there when he takes you through a real
case why someone falsely confessed and I
think if anybody reads that they can
start to understand it the other major
category is after all this being told
that your you know your your DNA is at
the crime scene we found your
fingerprints and then the police
officers start saying you know you
probably blacked out I mean this happens
all the time they'll start saying I
blacked out before and I don't remember
and you get the person's start
questioning their memory and this goes
back to the valuable memory problem
where the person will start saying you
know what I I must have done it then and
I just don't remember then the officer
will help them remember and then after
three or four hours later when they've
had the officer tell them how the crime
happened so many times and they've
pictured in their mind while the officer
was telling them they started confused
what's real memories versus what they
just pictured earlier and and many
people who have been exonerated who gave
these false confessions describe that
process where you know they just
confused me and I started to question my
own memory and I didn't think cops could
lie and I thought well god I must have
done it and then and then so I I just I
just came up with these memories but I
know they're not there now false and you
know if somebody's listening to this and
they're confused by this I encourage you
to study the problem of malleable
memories I talked about it in my book
there's a whole chapter dedicated to it
but an easier way is just Google
Elizabeth Loftus or TED talk at 17
minutes long it takes you through this
and explains very easily how that can
happen the book is fascinating it's
called blind and justice a former
prosecutor exposes the psychology and
politics of wrongful convictions we've
been speaking with the book's author
mark Godsey whose co-founder of the
aiyoh innocence project mark thanks so
much for talking to us about this thank
you appreciate you have me on